let me tell you about Matt R 5 years ago
Matt R used to open for me and he hit me
up and he was like hey bro I'm I'm
having trouble getting an agent do you
think you I go let me call my agency let
me put a word in for you so I call my
agency I say you guys you thought about
Matt r no I go what do you mean do you
know him yeah we're familiar I go the
kid's a home run he's really good-look
really funny he's young he's a great kid
he's not a [__] I go he's got all
the I'm telling you the kid is a star
and whoever takes him is going to make a
lot of money the kid is is a star and
they were like no we're going to pass
and now look at Matt R and my agent
every time I see my agent I go hey
remember when I offered you Matt R he
goes I know I
know next time you offer me somebody I'm
taking them cuz I offered him Theo Von
as well at that time wow I said Matt r
with Theo Von they were like n we're
passing and I'm like you're [__]
idiots who how do you run this business
when you don't know when you can't spot
the talent